hello bill great to be here in the man
cave this is the professional extension
of the man cave this part is a this is
where real work gets done this is the
only part in the building it's worth it
just to see it oh really I thought of
and I did not expect this but you know
as I was just telling you off the air I
invited myself on this show yes I will
you requested it I think you're doing
we're coming back on the air real times
coming back in a few days and we always
do something to promote it openness
let's do that show you know I like that
show oh I can't do the shows I listen to
got that Mexico should put that in there
it looks like it should be a ring for
maybe for a slash a roadie what season
you guys coming into oh [ __ ]
I don't know seasons it's hard to yeah
just couple years we started on HBO in
2003 but then we used to do but the
first few years they had us do two
seasons they took us took them a while
to get the idea that this is not like
The Sopranos or any other show this kind
of show is a habit show it has to be on
most of the year we used to do a season
from February to like May and then we'd
be off for four months and come back for
a few months in the fall that's not the
way you can do it when you're following
events a live show so finally somewhere
in there
they just okay so then it was one long
season as opposed to two so I guess they
counted the early years is too we've
been on HBO since 2003 but of course it
started you were on the old show
politically incorrect somebody sent me a
clip of that Wow I couldn't even bear to
watch it just from the way we looked it
was too sad time is cruel it's actually
we look better now just because we look
douchier younger of course I mean that's
the trade-off and yes
at your douchier when you're younger
yeah do look more pristine shall we say
unless beaten down by time yeah but that
started in 93
so I've already passed my we did a 25th
anniversary show about a year and a half
ago yeah in the fall of 18 it aired I
couldn't believe that do you know
they're trying to bring back politically
incorrect who was pay whoever the [ __ ]
they are it came to me rip the heads
that's so funny cuz I suggested that a
while ago with it not with me hosting it
of course but it was somebody else
hosting it but I don't have to ask my
manager about that I thought we I guess
we sold it I think mister when we moved
to ABC must be ABC when we move to ABC I
think we probably sold them the rights
to the show which is was probably stupid
but at the time it made sense and well
good luck with it I'm not doing it it
was one of those questions my manager
calls me up and says you're not gonna
want to do this but I'm obligated to
tell you why wouldn't you want it just
doesn't seem like something I wanna do
no I'm insulted no I'm just I would
never want to take over your show I
don't exist and then I've got it
stripped away though I'm saying
something though the whole thing was
like you once someone does a show leave
it alone you know right leave it yeah
like if you left and they started doing
real time with Adam Carolla right you
know which is exactly what they will be
doing a new [ __ ] show you know right
do you feel constrained by the time by
the the our format sometimes I was on
with Howard Stern recently and I was
saying that to him and I feel the same
sometimes when I watch or listen to you
it's it's funny a mirror I don't get
America like people's attention span is
either seven seconds or three hours yeah
no there's no in-between
well there's a lot of us that's what it
is this decided April yeah exactly
people the shortest attention spry see
this is all they have Rizal that's their
that's not true but it takes a big risk
too
three hours I mean there are virtues and
vices to both of them I mean I do like
being forced to condense and for people
I always think of the person watching my
show is the person who is interested in
current events but doesn't have the time
to follow it during the week they've got
kids and jobs and lives they are gonna
watch me to catch them up and it's my
job to obviously entertain them but also
to point out what's important what what
happened this week that you should know
about somewhere in that live hour
whether it's in the monologue or in new
rules or the editorial I do at the end
or in the panel somewhere I want to
cover everything I think you should
doesn't necessarily mean it's the things
that the newspaper or other outlets
thought was important what I think is
really important that's what I'm going
to cover so there is something to be
said for condensing it's also a lot to
be said for letting it breathe you know
I mean letting it breathe I do miss that
sometimes I wish I could and very often
we're in the middle of a discussion and
I have to move on I feel like what way
things are going now with streaming like
I know HBO has their new streaming
service maybe they could just give you
an option to let some some of those
conversations lengthen out it just seems
like some of them you're just getting
started and you have to cut them off
you're right and again sometimes people
just want the headlines very often I'm
reading something and it's too long I
just think just you should have given me
the New York Times starts every article
not just tell me what happened yeah
don't give me the background and on a
rocky road in Afghanistan as Fran
Lebowitz one said and just get to the
part I care about right movies are too
long lots of stuff is too long
people need editors but these kind of
conversations lend themselves more than
most art forms to just letting it happen
and yeah it's more natural I mean I like
the fact that unlike my early days when
you sweat backstage and you'd hear The
Tonight Show band playing it's wrong you
know Johnny's gonna ask you this and
then you're gonna say that neither
listen don't [ __ ] beer from this
you're getting trouble and this is good
I didn't prepare anything yeah you know
obviously you didn't prepare anything
okay I did you really have no list the
question oh no I don't you I like you
right I'm sure I'm not gonna run out of
things to ask you or talk to you about
but that's a talent in itself that you
could do that off the top of your head I
think you think it's not that much of a
talent but trust me a lot of people
could not do that I don't know if I
would trust myself have you said you
have two hours with this guy I I would
were I would it was be in the back of my
mind like [ __ ] what if an hour and 10
minutes in I'm like [ __ ] I can't they go
one more thing I can't imagine if you
and I were at dinner together for two
hours we would run out shits talk about
that's probably true so that's this okay
it's the same [ __ ] followed by dead air
why completely dead air listen man I've
been a fan of yours for a long time I
bought true story and I have you Wow
yeah I bought that book way back in the
day man I was living in New York it was
a great book thank you very underrated
book on standby yeah it's a novel yeah
no it's a novelization of my early life
very accurate though like it's you could
feel like you lived the life and you
know the names were hilarious of the
characters each other no I worked
probably harder on that than almost
anything I've ever done I would never
really yeah I would never write another
no but well just to make every sentence
every paragraph funny or telling no
extra words to me that's the kind of
what you did you write that I funny I
started it in the early eighties when I
was still almost living it and I would
get busy and put it aside not to look at
it for years and then I did a it's my
old life in 1985 in December I went down
to as he want in a home ex
code to do the memorable TV movie TV
movie there does appraise the date ship
the memorable TV movie club Med I think
we all remember it no we don't Linda
Hamilton was the star I think I do
remember it I hope you don't I remember
Linda Hamilton okay in a movie yes right
you now I'm picturing it it was a TV
movie and we stayed at the Club Med I
was in you know you it was kind of a
low-budget thing as far as the people in
the cast and crew went because we stayed
at the Club Med which was not a Club Med
it's not a luxury hotel
you know what Club Med's are you you
give up your money you pay everything in
beads but you don't really need money
and the rule is for people who just
you're gonna enjoy the outside that's
why you're in Mexico so the room is
monastic right
there's no TV cuz you're out all day you
know you're just gonna be in the waves
and then you're gonna [ __ ] and go to
sleep and whatever so I had a lot of
free time because I wasn't in the shot
every day but I was in Mexico eventually
I got [ __ ] cabin fever down there you
know I couldn't wait to get home but as
they're a long time and had nothing to
do and I wrote a lot of the novel there
and put it away again
and then I was in a real career slump in
the early 90s I had finished with acting
mostly I didn't want to do that anymore
I'd done a few sitcoms and I didn't want
to be the office creep forever and so I
was just like nowhere and that's when I
finished it and also that's like the
year I did cocaine which I probably
would not have finished it without that
it was only one year it was one year I
was never meant to do cocaine when
everyone was doing it I never wanted it
you know me I'm a pothead like you I I
it's not my drug but you know if you
really insist you can get in you can get
into any drug and I and I just happen to
be at this point in my life where I was
vulnerable to any I had nothing to do
all day I wasn't working
so and it helps you write it helps on
activity it's a Productivity dry was
never a drug that I liked because I
wasn't social on it but I could I used
to like to have sex on it well most men
did not I love that and and right but I
didn't want to talk some people are get
that guy I don't know is never that guy
who did coke and talk a blue streak no
but but it helped me you know
concentrate and organize and that kind
of stuff and you know and then I was
probably smoking pot - I was smoking
cigarettes it was not a healthy year
that was not a healthy year I remember
you know you because cocaine which is
kids that is the worst drug it really is
because you get a little honeymoon
period and then that quickly goes away
and then you're chasing that high and
you know it's not healthy and then you
know you're you're trying to at the end
of the night take the edge off you know
you're into that put the edge got to put
the edge back on I took it off too much
I'm drinking Jack Daniels damned now I
gotta take it off again I put it on too
much it's that was I never touched it I
got lucky you very smart I would
probably really enjoyed it I think I
would have really enjoyed it yeah that's
probably why did again at the beginning
yeah it's very much like a relationship
okay
good at the beginning you know I think
trails off I always say because
resentment or is it time and
relationships are good spoiler alert
it's the beginning for a lot of them for
sure now when you put that book out is
it still in publication another great
question I'm finding so much about my
own life here I didn't know because the
comics incorrect was being redone comics
from my era like guys who grew up in
general that when we were just starting
now there was a it was huge a lot of
guys pass it around a lot of guys yeah
hey you gotta get this book ya know I
mean and I tried to make it into a movie
there was many scripts written I mean
it's my own fault for not pushing that
through I
yes but I thought at the time it would
really would have made a a good movie
but it's Robbie too late now and well
you definitely have to change the names
now it's very hard yeah I did in the
script it's very yeah it's very hard to
depict stand-up comedy in a movie in
fact one of the original impetus to
write the book was that no one was doing
that well I remember that movie came out
with Tom Hanks
remember that punchline punchline okay
and Tom Hanks was good I mean Tom Hanks
could could have been a stand-up comic
he did it as good as you can passable
passable but they just never capture the
whole essence of it and also when you're
trying to have someone I see this on
Mazal know I haven't seen that yet some
show oh the one I think it's Jim Carrey
show on Showtime about oh I'm dying up
here thank you yes and I like the show
but whenever you're showing a stand-up
comic and you're and it's acting you're
acting as a stand-up and then the
audience has to laugh yeah there's
something about it that isn't it just
you can tell it's not real it's like a
boxing scene in a movie same thing a
little bit yeah yeah rocky right yeah
but that's sometimes purposely
over-the-top this just comes off as fake
because one thing we love about comedy
is that laughter is involuntary yeah
it's in you can't as any giant comedy
star knows you can walk out at a comedy
club and you'll get the biggest ovation
in the world two minutes later you can
be dying because it's involuntary has to
thrilled to see you but then if you
don't say something funny they can't
they're not gonna laugh it's also a very
uniquely live thing it's like you have
to be right I always say that like if
you watch a special on TV you're really
you getting 60% of funny you're right
you have to be there live you if you're
there live you'll get 100% of it so not
only that not only you watching it not
live right because you've got a
recording of it but now it's also a fake
recording so it's a guy pretending to be
on stage and
audience pretending to be an audience
and the whole thing yeah disaster yeah
so maybe it's a blessing in this guy job
of capturing the the marvelous mrs.
Mazal does of capturing like the early
scene in clubs like of her going up
drunked and talking [ __ ] and then people
telling her like you could probably do
comedy like it seems chaotic and real
but it it gets a little less realistic
as time goes on but you watch that show
and yeah yeah I like the first two
seasons the third season only I hope
they're not losing me here I mean it
takes place in the 50s yeah yeah yeah I
would watch something like that except
it's just too much first was just too
much so many thanks to watch yeah I mean
I put it on my list but you know I'm
gonna get to that and does everything
have to be like a season you know does
everything have to be so drugged back to
our subject everything is either very
condensed or way too drawn out and you
have to follow it and you're not like an
episode of friends
well you don't have to know what the
[ __ ] happened the week before and you
just tune in the Seinfeld it's not
dependent upon the week before right
it's all everything's an arc and people
binge
I don't binge I never binge ten ething i
I have the opposite problem I have
watching a DD I when I I love to watch
TV it's the last thing I do before I
sleep at night
but unless something is absolutely
compelling
I don't watch more than 15 minutes of it
I'll watch 15 minutes of this and then
15 minutes or that and fifty meant
something else thing and then go to
sleep you know people are structuring
their Netflix specials that way because
of that people are doing their closing
bit first I read that somewhere that
yeah you have to we have to grab them
yeah that's why every [ __ ] drama is
something and then six months earlier
yeah you know we have to go back because
you have to grab them first and then and
it's such a tired trope yeah you know
it's like now that we've seen it a
hundred times think of something else or
just go really crazy and do something
linear well it's you know this whole
thing that you were saying before we do
have a second
seven-second attention span or we have
three hours I would love to see someone
try to make a movie like Steve McQueen's
LeMans because if you don't remember
that movie old Steven yeah old Steve
McQueen there's no kids there was a
Steve McQueen before the very talented
director oh I didn't know there was a
director Steven yes you do
who is he was it just Peter he'd direct
what you know right he directed he's an
african-american he directed 12 years of
slave okay
are you are you using your magic my body
to go war and what else to do he's a big
director he said he's a major major guy
that Steve McCoy oh there he goes I
didn't know he has shame widows yes he
just did widows widows 12 yeah okay
anyway I remember the old state yes who
died of cancer 1980 I believe I remember
I'm chasing cures in Mexico right yeah
yeah
lung cancer I think probably like he
probably was a heavy smoker and hmm but
yeah he was he was what about him the
movie Lamont's is a real slow beginning
there's no talking for like the first I
don't know how many minutes it's just
you know people going about their life
on the racetrack like all preparing for
things no there's no chat
oh you ever try to watch a Hitchcock
movie oh yeah same thing yeah I mean it
just shows how different the audiences
are and how we have developed or
undeveloped I don't know if it's that or
if it's that there's an expectation that
people have a short attention span so
that everything is made for that
expectation no they do they do yeah I
think they I do think they really do I
mean the more you I do I I must say as
someone who grew up when Alfred
Hitchcock was still was he still making
yeah he made a movie in 1972 I was 16 I
saw it in the theater it was one of his
last he was on his last legs but psycho
had was 1960 I was too young to for that
but he was still very in vogue and a big
director
and I tried to watch I did watch the one
he made in 1956 the year I was born
called the man who knew too much I think
the story he made three times he liked
that story about the innocent guy who's
being chased by somebody and he doesn't
know why they're chasing him and the
police are after him but he's got to
find the bad guys before the police find
him it's Jimmy Stewart and Doris Day it
is I mean they talked about the master
of suspense I mean Jesus Christ is like
the master of keeping me from falling
asleep it's really subtle slow I'm sorry
but I think they've improved on that I
do maybe that's sacrilege to the movie
community and Martin Scorsese he'll
write me a letter or something but Jesus
Christ I'd much rather watch salt mmm
you know there's a thriller that robes
or the Jason Bourne those movies I feel
like they took what Hitchcock was doing
and yes they revved it up and I'm glad
they did Hitchcock's hard to get through
we also have to realize when Hitchcock
was making films they've been only
making films for 50 years there's a real
even left yeah I mean he started in the
late 30s right you know I mean talkies
had only been around for like 10 years
way back yeah yeah so I mean there's
something about that like even when you
think about stand-up like if you ever
tried listening to Lenny Bruce
I certainly have good example yeah I
can't do it doesn't work anymore
it's contextually we're in a different
world but any of those old schoolers
yeah that's the point at that funny it's
it's in true story where I talk about
how those guys who are such icons
couldn't make it today because they take
too long you could take you could take
two minutes before you got to the
punchline you could take two minutes to
set something up
the audience was perfectly okay with
that you could never do that to the Jack
Benny
Bob Hope was more rapid-fire but a lot
of these old schoolers you know I mean I
have a never funny list and it's been a
friend of mine created years ago and
some of them are on it you know Danny
Thomas I don't know when Skelton I mean
there's some people I thought were never
Bill Cosby I must say so it was on that
list really oh yeah you know I thought
he was funny never thought he was funny
even when he was doing Bill Cosby
himself like back at the album days and
I may have missed some stuff he did but
everything I ever heard even when I was
a kid I saw him on TV I'm like no I feel
very very ahead of my time I never liked
him
well it was one of those things where if
you had said any of this that you're
saying ten years ago people have been
furious at you well now these been
exposed
somebody told me he was a creep back in
1983 okay someone told me in 94 yeah so
it was somebody I liked not somebody I
was romantically involved with but a
girl who he was horrible to and I never
liked him after that as a person that
makes sense I had heard from people on
the set of news radio that he drugged
girls it was like one of those weird
things you heard as a room like why does
he do yeah he drugged girls like Bill
Cosby Brett cause be Bill Cosby we're
talking about the same guy not like
Steve McQueen Steve McQueen we'll get
him confused right no I mean dad America
and you have to wonder why a guy who
could get laid
yeah even as a married man that's
obviously a sick kink he had but I also
know a guy who was a promoter and and
told incredibly ridiculous stories about
things that Bill Cosby did that were not
sexual but just informed me that what
his kink is is part of a much larger
sickness about control yeah and making
people do weird things
as he can let me tell you what I heard
you tell me what you heard I heard he
makes people watch him eat curry he
would make the whole staff come into his
dressing room and watch him eat I hadn't
heard that exactly but it's exactly in
line with what I heard that he would do
things like make you what was one of
them like he would order food and then
he would say you know scoop out the the
doughy part of the hamburger bun after
you wash your hands and put it back on
the hamburger or once he asked them to
send him the soap that he hadn't
finished using in the dressing room like
blended to send it yeah just like crazy
crazy [ __ ] that again speaks to a
pathology that's larger than what we
know about him sexually that that fear
as a subcategory under that because to
need to have the woman be unconscious
yeah that's that's a weird thing I can't
I can't I can't get into there's certain
things I think I can't even imagine why
someone would find it attractive most
could be with a child no I can't
understand why that would be appealing
to you I can't understand this you know
a lot of things I can't understand I
worked at a casino and he made the
security guard talk him into bed yep and
shut the lights off he had like a whole
routine that he wanted them to follow
and he wanted them to tuck him into bed
yeah well I had a friend who had an
interesting take on it and he said there
is something that happens to some famous
people's particularly famous people who
were famous a long time ago where they
feel like they are better than other
people
there is a giant gap between them and
other people and they feel like they can
do things to people and they what yeah
yeah I don't think that's on
but his pathology but most people try to
hide that well I think that feeling they
try to I think he did you know it's
called acting yes
that's why when they're in front of the
camera they're so charming but we know
that behind the scenes they're they're
not but he seemed to wear it on his
sleeve well sort of sometimes right but
the other thing that he was doing in
publicly she was trying to chastise
other comics for using bad words and you
know he had a lot of weird control
issues with that as well but my friends
taking on was that he thinks that there
are people that they get to this
position where they think that they're
owed things and he thought about that
sexually - he said he probably felt like
he was just so above those women that he
didn't even want to negotiate with them
it just drugged them and [ __ ] them
because he's Bill Cosby and they should
be happy you know it's crazy it's no
it's not you know the human mind is the
bottom of the ocean it's mostly
unexplored a giant mystery well
especially that kind of scenario I mean
how many human beings have ever
experienced what he's experienced he's
been famous since the 1950s right he was
an American icon right is rich beyond
measure groundbreaker and a legitimate
world-class stand-up comic who toured
the whole world created yes Cosby show
that was a groundbreaking television oh
yeah so many factors so many factors and
then on top of that a psychotic pervert
and a creep and drugging women I mean on
top and who knows what else other
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're probably not just
that no you know when someone's that
[ __ ] up it's probably not just they
might find like 30 dead cats in his
backyard I mean who knows the [ __ ]
guys in - well I somebody told me it
just may not be true that he was
drugging people with animal
tranquilizers nuts he had a vet's
license or something that's how way
that's how he was because people were
like how did he get the stuff that he
was using for the knockout pills would
this would it offend you if I put my
finger not at all why would it is a man
that's a man maybe if I don't ask you
you're relaxed you're feel good I put my
feet
oh great you got some loafers on purpose
those are your choice you wore those
today I didn't even think about it see
that's why I'm saying I love my sweat I
did this because I don't have to think
about pulling my wardrobe but what I'm
gonna wear and yeah
is Johnny gonna like me oh boy did you
the night show with Johnny thirty times
holy [ __ ] 1982 to 1992 wow yeah thirty
times yes which just shows you that show
was went out when I started to do it
there was such a proliferation of comics
that you could do that show thirty times
and that didn't make me famous I mean it
elevated me to a degree of legitimizing
you in show business but that at one
point just doing the Tonight Show once
made you a star
but part of what true story is about was
the comics frustration that they came
along at a time when it wasn't that
unique a thing anymore hmm there was too
many comics you couldn't swing a dead
cat without hitting a comic well no I I
have like in my Sirius XM radio in the
car the comic stations and I love them I
would listen and very often seed
somebody's name I've never heard of this
comic I'll never see it again
they're doing you know they play four or
five minutes of their routine it's very
professional it's funny I'm laughing and
who is this person just just and seemed
like an innumerable supply of very
competent stand-ups who have funny bits
about the ketchup bottle and I don't
know any of them and I guess they have
followings and mmm no you obviously you
go to clubs though Club [ __ ] no I'm
Nessen table sits like a you go back to
high school no I go to the high school
every day you do yeah we're so does Leno
and lots of belt Chris Rock I don't get
it I don't know why you want that first
of all cuz my friends are there I like
going there and talking to the other
comics that are there all the time
Wow and I like to do it because it keeps
me sharp I do that line up at the store
there's 13 other comics and the
but I worked alone I yeah but I'm saying
but that's my how I keep sharp is a or a
sharp as I can be is well also I gave up
on memorization years ago first of all
with all the pot I've smoked it just
wasn't gonna happen I've used what I
call the poor man's teleprompter for
it's got to be twenty years which is I'm
a music stand on stage and then I have
my notebook which has my bullet points
and I don't think the audience even
notices it after yeah it's very every
five minutes I'm very discreetly moving
the page and but that way I don't have
to memorize anything when I get home
from the gig I go through it I redo it
in the computer print it out and it's
it's it's just been the greatest thing
because I can say I can get to exactly
what I want to say I hate comics who
stand up there and go what else what
else like [ __ ] that you should know what
else you never hear me say what else to
it I know what else and I'm gonna tell
you I'm gonna try to condense it I'm
gonna give you the best show I can for
90 minutes and then leave you certainly
can do it that way yeah we all have our
own yeah everybody's got their own way
doing it yeah we are i I like to be
around a lot of other comics like a
large number of very good comics all the
time I think if you feed off each other
like I'm on the road all the time when
I'm on the road I'm with my friends I
you know I go and tour with other
very funny comics yeah but when I'm in
town I just like to be around as many as
I can
you should do my Hawaii gig one year you
know I have a study by rantin Natasha
and well she did it last year yeah I ran
into them and Maui I was like what I was
doing yeah you were there yes I was
there with my family we were just
vacationing next year's the 10th was
like it was like New Year's right yes
yeah I started this 10 years ago nobody
would booked it they all said Hawaii's a
dead market
and I found this promoter who was okay
I'll try it and it worked
of course Honolulu's a big city there
are a million people there yes and Maui
so we do Maui on December 30th and we do
Year's Eve in Honolulu and it's always
surprises and this year sarah silverman
did it and Bobby Slayton and we have
some sometimes some very well-known
musicians who join us
Woody Harrelson is also in Maui and
plays with this a little bit it just
even says in Maui - yes I saw him there
one year but maybe you'd consider
slumming and it's a great fun trip and
you're with comics and I've never
performed in Hawaii every time I go
there's just a chill well I'm gonna hit
you up on that okay I stopped doing New
Year's Eve shows on my own that's the
great thing about it I always hated New
Year's Eve what a [ __ ] day and the shows
at 8 o'clock so ok we it's just a show
it's a regular show right directly right
right now exactly it's a regular show 8
to 10 or maybe a little after 10:00 we
always the Hulk group sings smile at the
end of it I made that a tradition the
old Charlie Chaplin smile though your
heart is aching you know that one's sure
you'll have to learn it and ease us what
a weird gig and well it's New Years Eve
you got to do something as you send them
off it's only an hour and a half left in
the new year in the old year and I feel
like that was the propria Tenaya
comedian Charlie Chaplin it's a hundred
years old it was a hit in the 50s for
Nat King Cole Michael Jackson redid it
in the 90s when he was on trial for
child molestation chose to do a song by
Charlie Chaplin the most famous job
molester
that was Michael's way of the chapel was
a child molester well Charlie Chaplin
but I think back then they didn't call
it
that but yes he married no anything
yes he married like it was like Jerry
Lee Lewis he was like with 14 year olds
really Charlie Chaplin
yes I'm don't think I'm talking out of
school about Charlie Chaplin can you
conjure standing up there on your magic
lightbox Jamie and see if that what do
we didn't know that's child molester yes
Charlie Chaplin famous for it for that
and you know back then I don't think
they got you for it but what they did
what was the legal age back then
possibly none I don't know if they even
had such a concept I mean we're talking
about an era before and they weren't
letting women vote right teens they
didn't women didn't vote till 1920 I
don't know if there were child labor
laws I just don't know well Priscilla
Presley wasn't she like 14 when erect
yeah and that was Elvis was a child
molester - and that was the 50s right
right and that well he went into the
Army in 58 so that's when he met her in
Germany her father was a colonel and she
was 14 and of course he was 25 and a
giant rock star and he says to the
colonel would you mind if I took your
fortune year old daughter back to
America she can live with me at
Graceland and it'd all be good and the
guy says enjoy what the [ __ ] was wrong
with people back those are different
human beings said years ago no no we're
we're we're so different just yeah just
are I mean I'm a little older than Oh 16
year old Harris met actor Charlie
Chaplin 16 is not that's not even I
don't think the worst was the famous one
doesn't mean is there like you know
Chaplin the MER vert or child monster
yes there definitely is but yes died
young back then I thinking recently
people were just rougher yeah you know I
mean you and I I think walk the same
path very often talking about
we I think are progressives but we have
short patience with some of the fragile
yes well [ __ ] yeah okay and some of
that is just the way you're brought up I
think kids are coddled you know I think
they're indulged and that's the reason
why they freak out over microaggressions
and stuff and some of that is just I was
telling some in this story not a mutt
apropos of this just talking about
something else but it just reminded me
that here I'm a kid who had I think a
normal middle-class upbringing I
consider it an idyllic time I consider
it an innocence you couldn't buy today I
mean first of all I grew up in New
Jersey in the 60s there was no racial
issues because there was only one race
in town that's just the way it was I'm
not saying that's good it wasn't but
that's so there weren't racial issues
there weren't drug issues and an I
didn't try pot in high school may or may
be there was a rumor that a few kids
were doing it but that wasn't even a
thing there wasn't even any like divorce
it was really the land that time forgot
you know it was Leave It to Beaver land
and I was telling someone this time my
father who grew up in the depression
sheep I you know loved him dearly but I
don't think that's the wrong word and
sent us to an army friend of his as the
dentist and this is 1964 I was eight and
did not use novocaine and I remember
vividly like he I had like eight
cavities that had to be filled he said
if it hurts raise your hand you know has
to drill what it's okay so they're
drilling into me and then I'm riding
home up this big hill it was cold on my
bike with the tears freezing on my cheek
so get to the dentist yourself first of
all they wouldn't do that today they
don't like kids just be on their own
like get your ass to the dentist on your
bike get home after they
drill into you with no novocaine and I'm
saying I wasn't raised by bad people
yeah people were just rougher yeah it
was just a rougher time and I I wouldn't
recommend these things exactly
necessarily although getting someplace
on your own I don't think it's the worst
thing in the world but a little more of
that have you ever had Jonathan hate on
your show yeah
the coddling of the immediate line is
exactly about that and he believes that
you should let your kids roam around and
let them find their way home and there
is a movement for that yeah that's how I
was raised I was raised to come home
from from school fly into the house
change into my play clothes fly out the
door my mother never said where are you
going what are you doing and you know
we're gone yeah and again and Leave It
to Beaver town there was a six o'clock
whistle really yeah at the firehouse the
whistle went off time for dinner and
then you right and then you got your ass
home when you heard the whistle we
didn't have watches or followed sir you
know I don't want I mean I don't want to
compare it's a it's a different world
for sure between the way we grew up in
the way they're growing up today I don't
know what's better I don't know which
one's better there's certainly a lot of
babies today yeah but there's also a
thing today where we're we're giving
them access to information way quicker
so there's got to be and this is this is
not something that's been studied right
like what happens to a young mind when
it has access to almost anything as soon
as you get a phone you're given 12 year
olds 13 year olds phones and then they
have access to everything in the world
everything
porn porn instantly which I you know
you're talking into a libertine but I do
not think porn is benign I do not it is
not benign not not the way it is now on
the computer I mean it's it's rapey it's
[Music]
it's sites are you going to any any site
I'm not getting the rav4 but I think
well it's a nine please it's not it's
not it's domineering yes it's a lot of
things that I am not interested in even
in my fantasies I was doing a bit about
that in my last special like even in my
fantasies I don't want to choke anybody
yeah I I don't want to come on your face
I mean come on coming on your face that
that's not rapey or domineering or I
mean I find that off-putting and gross
it doesn't that doesn't move me and the
thing I don't get it but that's half of
what pornhub is well I think what half
of it is now is a lot of stepsister
stuff as like stepfathers stepsisters
about because people are trying to be
naughty and there's nothing naughty left
because like the idea horn originally
was like I can't believe these people
are having sex like go back and watch
porn from the 80s so they're just having
sex as [ __ ] choking come on you're in
a spitting yeah it's gross and it's it
and so I'm not surprised that kids have
mental problems [ __ ] yes I mean what
what's the first date or first real date
like when you saw you know a team of
Japanese businessmen come on some
schoolgirls face when you were dead well
you saw that one the bus it was a flight
attendant
yeah the there was a squid yeah oh
there's always squids there in the
octopuses [ __ ] yes yeah it's it's not
necessarily benign but neither's alcohol
neither's game but I mean if I was a
parent yeah yes away from the kid
there's also an issue that you don't
tell kids about it so they don't they
find out from other kids there's no
discussion of what it is there's no like
real no one in the right mind would ever
sit down and watch porn with their son
and say this is what I want you to avoid
like this is why I want you to avoid
that right but it's probably not the
worst idea I mean look
there comes a legality issue like I mean
I don't even think it's legal to watch
porn with a 13 year old kid but if you
if you have a son and he's 13 and you
know he's gonna be exposed to these
things you almost have a responsibility
to talk them through it and just give
him some to do some understanding of
what it what is the landscape here's a
big one why these girls doing this okay
here's something that people don't like
to admit that enjoy porn the vast
majority of them have been molested the
vast majority of who is porn our porn
actors porns that true yeah yeah yeah
there was some study they did on girls
who get into porn who have been sexually
abused mentally abused and physically
abused it was overwhelming it was
overwhelming I mean obviously it's just
anecdotal it's based on one group of
people that they I don't know it's not
just studies that's not not surprising
at all no so that they're searching for
acceptance and they're they're willing
to do something that's way outside the
norm
I'm sure there's just some girls are
just really promiscuous they're intersex
there's nothing wrong with them they
just rub it and they love performing
right I think there's less of them than
there are of the girls who were probably
abused and you know maybe they turn a
negative into a positive
I'm not saying I shouldn't do it I'm not
casting any judgment but I am saying
that you should understand what this
thing is like what this why how come
some people like to [ __ ] on camera never
everybody else is afraid to you know
that you're gonna see their genitals I
don't know about the watching rapport
with your son Joe but ya suggested
either I'm saying I'm kidding but what I
would tell a kid especially a boy is son
what you're seeing and porn don't think
that women really like that because they
don't they don't want to have somebody
come on their face someone must we saw
of course someone likes anything that's
one of the bad things about the Internet
is that you could in the old days if you
were some sort of weirdo pervert you
thought and it was the world was better
because you thought that you were
completely alone in the world now
whatever your kink is you could put it
on the internet you could write you know
I want a hooker to
[ __ ] on me while I play with electric
trains and it'll caddy around the house
of people in two minutes or saying me
too
yeah and that I don't have that value of
a community
yeah of electric train [ __ ] around code
chamber yes
enjoying [ __ ] on you right chains so
that's all unhappy but but I just don't
think that I mean that would be my main
lesson to it to adolescent boy okay we
can't keep the porn away from you just
don't think that's real the way real
women are or what real women like I
don't think they like tinder either in
fact I watched some documentary I can
remember what it was called I think it
was on HBO about dating on social media
and that was the main theme of it was
women are doing it young women but they
don't like it and it's not surprising
they don't like it guys are of course
wired very differently and they just
want to hook up and move on
I read also an article about it and the
I think it was in Vanity Fair and the
the woman says okay she did it once she
tried tender she goes to a hotel or
meets a guy she had just met over the
phone and they [ __ ] and then she said as
I was getting dressed I turned around
and he was sitting on the bed looking at
tender Wow you know so he had just come
and here he is looking for the next fix
victim and victim this is the feeling
participant yes how dare you I'm not
open right she's the next he's a writer
she was a willing predator how dare you
that's so exciting he's out there
hunting just try to get the ladies yeah
but women it's not designed for women
Sensibility no I'm not most women oh
they had
remember Ashley Madison yes the cheating
site mm-hmm and it was like 12,000 women
and 126 million men raise e number like
that and most
the webinar that were sake - there's a
lot of them that were fake they'd like
fake account it's yeah that was
hilarious when yeah but when you have a
dating site set up just for people that
want to cheat and then they all get
busted because someone hacks into it
like do you find Ami's use your real
name like Jesus Christ I mean just never
read that book sapiens yes such a great
book and he goes into the fact that
monogamy probably nuts what what is
wired in us it's the reason why there's
so much misery about relationships is it
probably wasn't that way in early man
and I'm saying early men like human Homo
sapiens which haven't been on earth that
long there's no primates that are
monogamous they've never found right and
we are primates right and we probably
had a system system it's just how we
were that was closer to the chimps and
where it was like communal fathered him
you know you didn't really know whose
kid it was so there wasn't this
possessiveness because you know I guess
the women [ __ ] different men in the
grouping and there wasn't that feeling
of I own you right and this pussy's mine
and all that bullshit's exit Don no it's
basically about that my friend dr. Chris
Ryan wrote it okay interesting that's
it's basically about that it's about how
people behave the polyamorous
relationships they had in these right
primitive cultures and that before DNA
testing and before they understood
paternity that's really what it was all
about about the community would raise
children everybody would rate and they
would there was a lot of like shared sex
in between different people so much so
much of love is I think possessiveness
what people think is love it's not love
mmm you know and and also you make me
feel good is not love either to me and
they always say love is the thing that
has never been able to be defined I
don't think it's that hard it's it's
selflessness it's when I care for your
happiness more than my own that's love
in any kind of relationship man or woman
well at least as much as my own yeah
right yeah and if if you being without
me would actually make you happier then
I'm for that that's love that's not that
would not characterize most of my early
relationships how I felt and what I
thought what love was
well it's interesting when we look at
other animals right because you blown
aagree nuts not love and other animals
monogamy isn't a choice like the animals
that are monogamous the monogamous they
don't have any desire like it's
naturally built and wired into their
system it's only they choose like swans
so there's a bunch of um penguins for
instance penguins yeah there's a
favorite Sergei we know that they all
look the same they might as well be gay
there aren't they're gay it wasn't there
a big thing about gay penguins well
there was a story I feel like about gay
penguins or really you know there's
something because I feel like the usual
suspects on the right yeah look up
Charlie Chaplin's gay [ __ ] [ __ ]
smile is something they were there maybe
it was a story something that made the
Evangelic o--'s mad about paying me yeah
but sanguine so I think it's Tanglin
maybe it's they were in my point would
be that any of these animals that are
doing this they're not doing this
because they have a choice they
understand what it is aw new york times
gotcha
gay penguins and their hope for a baby
have enchanted berlin two male penguins
at the zoo berlin after there that's it
that's what it is two male penguins
adopted an egg blurps delighting germans
but upsetting pat robertson big time i
was he bummed out about that yes
somebody's like that was or all of them
more I'm sure the Family Council those
types you think they want to have the
example of penguins being gay I wanted
it with that leave into a [ __ ] or if
it's just a hustle at this point do you
think they really give a [ __ ] about
these penguins being gay I think they
have to say something because it's some
new thing to talk about and it gives
them fuel for outrage
yeah a juicy story in the news they
could jump on yeah I mean Pat Robertson
is it he's still on TV right he said
yeah he's if he needs material like you
and I do yes or something yeah yeah yeah
you never know with these people gay
penguins that's where that's where you
draw the line all right Syd that's
enough they're dare agenda has moved
over to the Penguins such a strange time
so this strange time we're like we're I
feel like if you read steven pinker
stuff he talks about how this life has
never really been easier than we have it
today right but it's also probably one
of the reasons why people are so
outraged about things today is this
there's it's so there's less real [ __ ]
that's dangerous in this world there's
less there's still is real dangerous
seals real murder and real rape and real
robberies but there's less of it than
ever before but yeah there's more
outrage than ever before about nonsense
things well when societies get too
successful and you could make that claim
about America that's when they become a
feat and that's when they become soft
yes and that's when they fall this is a
story that goes back to ancient Rome and
other societies you you're you're a
victim of your success in a large way
we're we're that because yes people
don't we were just talking about how
people were rougher yeah no novocaine
you know that wasn't even the roughest
thing we don't know hardship except for
that sliver of the country that fights
the wars mm-hmm those people know
hardship of course we do have poverty in
America but there's also a fairly
substantial safety net that this country
has I mean no Paris in other parts of
the world but you know there's parts of
the world that are real with crime and
gangs yeah those people deal with real
hardship Oh real hardship these are the
people from central of the Central
American countries that they always are
freaking out about the Trump
administration because yes when gangs
ruled the country in El Salvador and
Honduras those places life is precarious
and easy to lose now but I know Steven
Pinker's point you know which is a great
point is like let's not forget that in
the last 20-30 years the amount of
people we've risen
out of extreme poverty the people who
used to live on a dollar a day it wasn't
that long ago when I read this that a
billion people defecate in the street
you know that's where they poop that's
all improved greatly now part of the
reason why Trump people are upset about
jobs and stuff and going overseas well
that's part of the reason why is because
we lifted out of extreme poverty people
all over the world but they took those
manufacturing jobs that's why they're
not living in extreme poverty and why
they're not pooping in the street
because they're making Trump ties as
opposed to somebody in Ohio so pick your
poison yeah I mean this is like what
we're talking about with us growing up
that life was rougher the life is easier
today and but you have more access to
information so maybe it could be better
and then things seem to be moving in a
better direction in terms of things
being safer less violence less crime
less rape and then people also get upset
at you bring up those statistics that's
where it's really interesting that
Pinker gets attacked for just stating
statistical facts just say and he's not
making value judgments he's just saying
hey things are if you look at the
overall numbers of things this is the
safest time to be alive ever it's many
people know but what about this what
about that like it's a horrible hallmark
of our era that we live in that facts
almost always come second yes your
political agenda comes first yeah and if
it doesn't fit in then we don't want to
hear those facts and that's the left and
the right it is the left and the right
it's both and it's it's it should be it
should be something that everybody
rejects it should be something that
angers everyone it shouldn't be tied to
one party or another party and it really
should be something that if there's a
there's a real problem with
communication in this society one of
them is the denial of actual facts and
information if we if we know things we
have rock-solid threats it's whether
it's about climate change whether it's
about war the budget whatever the [ __ ]
if you have a real number yes and you
want to spin and deny and like that
that's a giant problem it's a giant
problem right
I get madder at the left because I want
them to be better and they should be
better and they're they they're the
science party and they're supposedly the
fact people I expect this [ __ ] from the
right right denying climate change and
so forth they've been doing that for a
long time the left has it's dirty thing
if you disagree with them in any way you
become an all right person like right I
mean it's obviously a small sliver or
race doing this yeah boy I got stucked
in this all right category I'm like you
guys are out of your [ __ ] right
exactly voted right in my life right I
know but there's a there's a I feel like
I'm sure as you do sometimes a man
without a country ass yeah and there's a
group of a Sam Harris yeah see people
you've had on yeah Jordan Peterson
Barry Weiss yeah you know I just we're
all progressives yeah but sensible
progressive real addresses real
progressives were not blindly not be
liable to our party right and we don't
chase these virtues signalers yeah who
are always as a friend of mine said they
wake up offended yeah yeah and I I'm
always reading a story like daily I read
something and what goes through my mind
is this country now is completely binary
there's only two camps
we're totally tribal you read the red or
blue liberal or conservative and
everything that one side does that
anybody does that represents that side
has to be owned by that entire side
because people go you well you're the
party of so whenever there's something
on the left that's cuckoo crazy we all
own it yeah and that's one reason why
Trump won sure because people you go
through the polling his fans are not
oblivious to his myriad flaws what they
love about him what they all say they
love is he wasn't politically correct
it's it's hard to measure how much
people have been choking
that political correctness they do not
want to walk on eggshells yeah they do
want do not want to think that one
little misstep and they'll get fired or
be castigated and these are not just
famous people I mean these are the
regular people and I think when someone
reads the kind of stories you see every
day
and it's an eye roll and it's a I roll
at the left that's when you lose people
a giving example is about two weeks ago
the Giants my football team the New York
Football Giants cut took his name is Jim
Norris Jenkins and our word yes we have
to say the r-word
no you could say [ __ ] okay well look
we're just we're not saying it I don't
know what the [ __ ] rules are yes and
he okay first of all I don't understand
why that generation feels the need to
engage with their fans on Twitter but he
was and some God needs to teach him
social media some guy was criticizing
him and he's a good cornerback or safety
and whatever he is
and the was criticizing him and he
answered back yeah again I don't know
why but saying here are my stats I'm
pretty good I only can do my job right
I'm not [ __ ]
mr. Iran must be nice part of the story
I'm gonna explain so then the guy the
fan says well why does it matter the
team is losing and that's when jinora
jenkins said I can only do my job
[ __ ] and cut like cut from the team
cut like the next day and first of all I
think he said it's something I thought
it was a hood thing you know maybe
jinora Jenkins didn't get the memo
because he's not you know like on
Twitter 24/7 and living with the woke
stirs that we don't do this anymore
I think they offered him a chance to
apologize he said I think he did did he
I think he did did after they caught him
but yeah I don't think he likes to
insist on saying that's were you know
there seems like there's no room anymore
for someone just to go
sorry I didn't realize this was such a
thing because you know they do move the
goalposts
we're often and they like to because
it's easier to catch people that way so
how about just oh sorry I guess you know
we don't do this anymore my bed and move
on with our lives instead of no you're
canceled your cut
you are irredeemable yeah it's hot
ridiculous it's ridiculous and what I'm
saying is like every day there's some
story like that and it just all goes
into the bin left-wing yeah and that's
when people go you know what Trump's an
[ __ ] I don't like him but I don't
want to live in that world these people
are even [ __ ] crazier yeah and that
is the great danger of reelecting him
and that very well may do it yeah it
very well may yeah the this
overcorrection and overreaction and
things like that a fury AIT's people and
they love it when Trump says crazy [ __ ]
because it sounds like something that
they would say he's trolling like he had
that one speech was talking about China
this is the way you talk to China say
listen [ __ ] yeah yeah that
alone like I even laughed and clapped I
was like that's [ __ ] hilarious
because that is what you would hope some
crazy version of a president would say
that would never really exist but all
the sudden he exists he sometimes he
says something that I totally do not
want a president to say but if he wasn't
president like for example when he was
confronted may have been by Bill
O'Reilly when he was still extent about
Putin killing journalists or something
and Trump said something like well we're
not so innocent either yeah now I don't
think the President of the United States
should say that but you know well says
that Noam Chomsky yeah that's like
something Noam Chomsky says America's
guilty of also being doing these
horrible things we're not innocent
either yeah he would be a little bit
more articulate about it but yeah right
yeah but the point is that no one judges
anymore by the content of what they say
it's just by whose team are you on
yes so if you liked it when norm Noam
Chomsky said it you shouldn't hate it
that much when Trump said
or vice-versa if you hated it the nun
chump you said it then you should hate
it the Trump said it but that's not how
people react well the team thing is so
prevalent that even when he does
something militarily like backs out of a
country you see people on the Left
criticizing him for not not going in or
not not engaging like Jesus Christ you
guys are supposed to be the people that
always don't want to war and when
someone who's the president does
something that's not a move towards war
we should all be saying yes please more
of this he's got a good thing here's a
good thing it's not like we want to
categorize people as being like you said
one or zero binary irritable like either
chosen or irredeemably careful with how
you talk or you get labeled in in one or
two of those categories and people are
so scared now communicate it's I had a
conversation with a friend a while back
and he we're crazy conversation it was
alcohol involved but he said something
really ridiculous
he was saying that maybe it's good that
women get so much money in divorce
because of all the [ __ ] they've been
through for men over the years and I was
home buddy I'm like with that what does
it have to do with money and divorce
like if that's an individual person
that's getting money from another
individual person is she getting is she
collecting is this like reparations for
all the horrible things that have
happened for women and he goes well
indeed so he starts getting defensive he
goes well what about income inequality
the women have to deal with I go oh
Jesus I go well you know that's not real
right and he goes what do you mean I go
it's not like there have the same jobs
it's not like both women the man and a
woman are both male men they both do the
same amount of houses but the man makes
a dollar when the woman makes 70 cents
that's exactly what it is I go the [ __ ]
it is not what it is illegal is it is it
legal already passed I explained right
everybody walked on eggshells
everybody's right oh geez
what are you saying right you're saying
income inequality is not real right no
it's not not that it's not real there's
so many of those mic drop yeah raises
that yes you know kids and cages which
of course we don't want kids in cages
but there's a whole discussion to be had
about immigration yeah as opposed to
just kids in cage or Islamophobia of
course that is a real thing
exists but there's a whole other
discussion but just these look the left
often uninformed yeah they just are but
they have these bullet points that they
feel like they definitely can shut a
conversation down that's what I mean
they don't feel like they have to learn
a lot about a subject yeah because you
have these mic drop sayings or phrases
that just stop people from talking
well I'd fortunately known the actual
statistics and so when we were talking
about I was saying no no take choose
different jobs and also they negotiate
for themselves differently yes they need
to negotiate for themselves better well
that's one of the things when people
accuse Jordan Peterson to be in sucks
it's you know Jordan Peterson literally
counseled and coached women how to be
more assertive when their jobs to get
better raises sure it was really
explaining how to do this and and and
just even maybe possibly against your
better instincts to exert yourself and
show that you understand your value and
this is what men do and this is why men
get raises and oftentimes women just
kind of keep it to themselves and
they're a little nervous about it but it
is amazing I mean you mentioned divorce
yeah they don't assert as well going for
a raise but oh the divorce thing think I
mean as I can go both ways if the woman
is the one who has more money yeah but
when the [ __ ] does that ever happen
that's like women who beat up men women
even beat men up to like when I hear
that oh my god I'd go to the gym yes you
should go to the gym man it's like these
fights men's rights [ __ ] are like
there's so much to make fun of men's
rights guys but well I had one of them
on my one of my comedy specials I had a
bit about it where they were saying you
know that men get raped more often than
women I go yeah by other men you [ __ ]
idiot exactly
chicks are out there rape and dudes what
do you think others are and there were
stops abuse Tina Hoff Sommers yes okay I
love ya yeah I love her so she was on
our show recently and you know we were
talking about the fact that also they
don't bring up a lot of the time that
most of the horrible dirty jobs in the
world yes are done by men yeah they're
the ones who are up
the telephone pole most likely dying the
job most likely to be murdered and most
likely to go to jail yeah most likely to
get a much longer jail sentence yeah for
the same crime so we're not crying about
being men
we're just saying as she says life is a
complex yes mixture of advantages and
disadvantages yeah I think the pendulum
swinging the other way though I think
really dumb statements like [ __ ] all
white men like we used to hear on
Twitter and people who still like
applaud and retweet it I think people
are now like oh [ __ ]
well that's a little out there but I
have heard when now it's going in the
other direction because the race is
winnowing but at the point of say six
months a year ago when lots of people
were getting into the race at some point
there were 24 Democrats in there and
when a white guy would get in it was
very common to hear do we need another
white guy yeah and that was completely
okay yeah on the left and it's like okay
but then we are saying that we are using
race yes to judge whether someone is
qualified well right yeah exactly we are
using race and gender to say whether
someone is qualified just so we
understand what we're doing here because
I don't think that's exactly what Martin
Luther King meant when he said judge by
the content of their character and not
the color of their skin which seems to
elude the promised form of identity
politics and it's really ridiculously
dumb when they don't realize that that
same sort of strategy is gonna come
right back around at you it's like
people to think the other guy's pissing
me off I'm gonna go [ __ ] punch him
well guess what he's gonna punch you
back like this is this is not it's not
that simple when you if you go around
judging people based on their gender and
their their color and their race guess
what they're gonna do that to you now
like this is it's it's a terrible
strategy I want an ID I want to know how
the divorce laws came to be I do I want
to know somebody must have written a
book on it I just want to know how we
got to this place where you know first
of all this idea that you have to live
in the style of which you've become
accustomed I can help you here again
great a couple couple ways here's the
big one lawyers make a lot of money if
there's a large settlement
so it's lawyer yes lawyers don't make a
lot of money if there's no settlement
you know Phil Hartman when he was
getting divorced one of the things that
he said to me I go do just [ __ ] give
her half come on man you make a lot of
money goes it's not half he was crazed
he's like it's two-thirds he was the
[ __ ] lawyers get a third it's goddamn
family and I've had friends that have
gotten divorced and even though they
were they had come to an agreement with
the axe like let's listen well this this
and you'll get this and I'll get this
fine then the lawyers jump in he's
trying to [ __ ] you and the snow they're
trying to [ __ ] you over ya deserve marks
exactly the plot of the movie marriage
WC marriage it's terrific I was again it
at the beginning because it was about an
actress and a theater director and I'm
like Jesus [ __ ] Christ can't you at
least pretend that there are people in
America not outside of your exact circle
they've been so many big movies you know
that are just about your world of show
business have a little creativity make
them something else but okay I got over
that and then it's just a terrific movie
about there's no bells and whistles it's
just we're married we seem very happy
and then well we're not happy and we're
gonna get divorced and then we're gonna
let's just do it amicably and not
getting lawyers involved and then it all
falls apart and once it goes down that
path that you're talking about it just
becomes as vicious as anything yeah
without guns well I had a friend who got
divorced and no nope family okay no
children didn't have children and it
dragged on for more than I think almost
three years and even though they had
come to some kind of sort of conclusion
he was paying for his wife's lawyer I go
like you're paying for the general of
the army that's trying to kill you
you're paying for someone to [ __ ] you in
the ass yeah you're getting [ __ ] in
the ass bro it's my feeling I have seen
so many men broken by I stated every
time somebody says you know they people
unfortunately get a horrible disease
like cancer and
say I couldn't have gotten through it
without my wife I always think yeah and
maybe she gave it to you I don't mean of
course literally but I just mean that
when you're in a bad relationship the
stress yeah we don't know what
contributes all the things to cancer but
that certainly is I'm sure one of them
and then going through a divorce like
that I've seen people like like you say
just broken they get wrecked and it's a
system the reason why the divorce laws
are set up the way they're set up people
think oh we're protecting women
horseshit they're doing it so that they
can extract the maximum amount of money
out of the male that way the lawyer gets
the biggest chunk that they could
possibly get most lawyers have a working
on the percentage basis right especially
if a woman doesn't have as much money or
if she's you know the loyal come to our
look we've got a deal here we'll we'll
figure this out don't pay me now we're
gonna make sure we get you the most
we'll we'll take care of it all in the
end and this is what has happened to
several of my friends that have been
divorced and you know what it is once
you see it what I get and I understand
and I accept and I support is child
support
I mean I've I grew up with a deadbeat
dad my dad never paid for [ __ ] and I
have many friends that have also
experienced a lot of financial hardship
growing up because their dad was a piece
of [ __ ] and didn't want to pay for the
children the people very close to me
including my wife but when there's a big
difference between that a man taking
responsibility for his children it's a
big demonstrating that and alimony
alimony is creepy there's something
creepy about like my friend like I said
didn't even have a child with this woman
he is still paying her by the way this
is the same guy a very good friend of
mine has been divorced for 14 years has
been married for 12 - a new woman still
paying the old woman and my joke was
like you [ __ ] us so hard she can't
work right like she literally can't work
because he's a wealthy man he made good
money and he works really hard he's a
he's not in the business he's a you know
he has a real job and he works you know
long [ __ ] hours every day
and he has his own business and he has
to pay hundreds of thousands of dollars
to someone he doesn't even talk to
anymore i scooted a [ __ ] guy I knew of
a guy was a doctor
who what did gel every night because he
couldn't make the payments Oh God and
they would like let him out on weekends
to do rounds and stuff but he was it's I
got a better one for you
why get in great yeah yeah Dave Foley
who's on Newsradio
sure when he was getting divorced was
when he was on Newsradio
so it was a financial peak you know he
was the star of the show he's making a
lot of money right and so his pain I get
to that we're set up for that sure so
this is in Canada right he the judge
tells him he tells the judge I don't
make that kind of money anymore that was
an extraordinary time in my life it's
very hard to make that kind of money you
know I'm an actor I just the doctors the
judge rather says your ability to pay
has no relation to your obligation to
pay Wow
think of that just pause here for a
moment what a statement you're and where
else would we say that it's insane and
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of dollars hundreds of
thousands like as if he's supposed to
conjure this up like his career Capote
was supposed to magically resurrect
itself in some really financial entity
is usually the man still who probably
has the more money and is paying the
woman
yes it's very anachronistic to how we
have come to think about women as equal
and strong and able to do everything we
can do but when it comes to this it's
like we got to take care of them
suddenly it's like they're very
dependent I think it's a scam that's
setup because the men in general are in
control the finance or make more money
and they can extract more money from
zillow turning it down yeah I mean
that's that's why the system I think is
set up the way it's set up it's it's
dark man I mean the only time it's
happened the other way that I know of is
Tom Arnold Thomas oh sure yes it does it
does happen this one he's gone for the
males
right we got one on the board there's
like if the board was like here if it
was it would be a [ __ ] billion
scratches on one side and four lines and
the one through it and then next to it
it's like Tom Arnold Tori I never a
couple of the dudes never understood the
concept of marriage because when people
would say why don't you want to get
married I'd say why would I invite the
federal and state government into my
loveless very important well you have to
have it otherwise it's not real if you
don't get it a signed piece of paper
what the [ __ ] do you have just your
feelings for that other not good enough
how should I tell her friends she's got
to tell her friends and he really can't
been brainwashed but he really can't see
she's trained you to say the right
answer well I think that's how crazy
crazy backward way to look at it that
without the piece of paper it's not real
it's not real whatever you have would
this summon emotionally that's what's
real the paper is what's fake you
shouldn't be worried about divorce
because we're never getting divorced I'm
not worried about you [ __ ] you're doing
like why why you're getting so upset
about this bill just sign the paper
okay get married we're gonna be together
forever I don't know what you're worried
about
Jesus Christ I'm freaking out but don't
you love me you're freaking out about
divorce we're not getting divorced we
love each other God sign it the darkness
clouds roll over haha but also like
humans change it's like we said it's so
funny when you you could say about
anything else well I'm not married to it
you know do you want that thing there
I'm not married to it but with a human
the thing that's most malleable were
like yep I'm gonna marry well the but
you know but for some people it works
fantastic I think it's some kind term
limits they actually have a marriage
terms like I don't think that's a real
thing I think it is really good yeah
google it some countries have like a
turn we did this before right yeah it's
real
some countries have like you could get
married for like selling oh I see and
then you have in here yeah and you could
decide the end of it we're good let's
get out of here right yeah well
that's putting a level of logic into it
that's probably not gonna really obtain
when the moment comes because that time
you're so codependent girls are not
gonna tolerate the other gonna let me
ask you this how long you been with Phil
and he wants a [ __ ] term limit right
my god you guys are gonna be together
forever what are you doing get the
[ __ ] term limit cuz I'm right if you
stuck with Dave I bet Dave what now
right he's not like that little boring
maybe sounds funny but there's a [ __ ]
I need to sign a contract you be fine
girl it's fine it's like when agents are
competing to sign you and they're like
you didn't read for that oh I could
there's a financial incentive with
anything things get squirrelly know what
I'm saying yeah but it also you know I
remember you it's funny you mentioned
Tom Arnold I had him on the very first
episode of politically incorrect I think
with Roseanne and they were talking
about marriage and he said the great
thing about marriage is when you have a
big fight and somebody says I'm leaving
you can go you can't we're married and I
got what he was saying some people like
that that you have this yeah this
self-imposed barrier that makes more
difficult it's like a waiting period
with guns you know or when they make you
look at the sonogram when you want an
abortion in some states look at your
[ __ ] baby on a computer screen there
and tell them come back tomorrow and
tell me you want to kill that kid you
know you have a waiting period you have
to cool off you can't just leave whereas
if you're not married you can right
unless you live together that's more
complicated or kids and more complicated
but yeah and the other one we got on the
board is Kevin Federline we got him -
what do you mean on the right Britney
baby daddy yep
he's a Ferrari right now absolutely
absolutely plus you got the [ __ ] Britney
Spears which is a double fist pump
is that a good thing oh yeah he hasn't
said one thing the whole time we've been
here for 16 hours she has not said one
word and that was the one thing that
made a sound come out of James she's got
two things in the majority she's hot and
she's crazy she's probably fantastic in
bed Britney but still hot there was a
photo of her recently on Instagram she
still looks hot as [ __ ] I said yeah she
was in a bikini I think she fell apart
might be I've never seen her in real
life you don't know until you see him
right right I mean I I didn't yeah I
guess I haven't that's right right now I
have been that's your right now yep
well that's a life no makeup no filter
no fur that's a lot of look at that
picture right there that's a lot of that
one looks crazy well I do not fine
oh she's called his [ __ ] with that that
one right there that weird thing is so
great left no no the right one in the
middle I do not listen if two o'clock in
the morning and you're both drunk
that's what you want I'm never drunk
anymore and now I go to bed at midnight
which is quite and my dad's here with me
because he has to be wherever I go I see
that country yes that well she's like 36
years old now into do you think she's
telling that well she does that there's
a whole free Britney movement from
people who can nothing better to do at
their time and there's no more issues of
all the issues in the country that you
couldn't adopt as something to take to
care about but people are saying because
yes she still is under that order that
her father has to run her life because
remember when she went and she went
crazy yeah yeah I think she always crazy
she just expressed it in a way that made
people concerned and also I think she's
a sweet southern girl who showbusiness
will make you crazy would that mean they
shed the paparazzi chased her like they
chased Lady Diana she couldn't leave her
house yeah and yeah that level of Fame
yes it is
we saw Elvis go through or Michael
Jackson go through or any-any
like right do they get you get to that
super pop star level yep no one can
handle it no and and it's it yes there
is a point where it's Fame I think we
know is terrific
mostly unless it gets to that point
right I mean when it
the people trying to help you when your
other people they're just looking at
like you know salespeople and people and
airline counters and people just look at
you like what the [ __ ] do you want
oh I don't know and just for you to do
your job but if they recognize you then
suddenly you get a smile I always say
being famous is like living in a small
southern town hello how you doing it's
so good to see you you know they're just
people just friendly in a way that they
sure aren't any more in big cities well
you know where they're still friendly
like that Dallas Texas oh yes the Texas
she's crazy
please all the south is still a
friendlier place
I love playing this out yeah I'm always
in the south I never considered tensions
the south it's kind of a young thing
it's sort of how it is the West you're
much as it is the south it's everything
it's a world where the south what we're
the south if you look at the south of
the country well with Southern
California where the west but we're also
the South Texas is a weird thing but we
know what we mean when we talk about
South Dixie yes and but Texas is so big
Austin to me is not Texan enough I might
as well be in New York you know it's
more like San Francisco like a slice
yeah yes I do I want the real barbecue I
like well not barbecue but I like that
that Texas flavor Houston I love I
always had a better it went back when I
used to go out after a show always had a
better time in the south than the north
much rather party in Houston and I don't
know Boston which is a beautiful city
and I love it and I love performing
there but I never found the party but
you can't miss it in Houston yeah you
know yeah a little more more jovial yeah
Joe feel it's interesting how we think
of the south to a good and Arizona's not
the south but it's [ __ ] for sure the
south I mean it's about ordering Mexico
yes
well Arizona yeah I mean they're there
they're bringing up the rear a little
bit strange spot a certain civilization
wise yeah you know there there's some
very concern it's the conservative best
Barry Goldwater country and sheriff joe
arpaio you know I mean there's some real
real cavemen yeah in Arizona but I'll
open carry state yeah but when you stick
to cities which we do you know we're not
playing theaters in the sticks it
doesn't matter what state you're in
you're always going to be and get a
liberal audience look at the election
map every year there's a lot of red but
anyplace there's a city it's a blue dot
especially if they have a college town I
played Birmingham Alabama it looks like
any place else at least the crowd coming
to my show I once was I think it was
Birmingham it was somewhere in Alabama
must have been either Birmingham or
Mobile and there was a bass fishing
contest or award show tournament
something going on like at the same time
as my show or maybe my show was starting
and it was letting out but there was
this I was driving up to theaters long
crowd of people coming to my show who
looked like it dressed like anywhere
else normal and then on the other side
of the street going the other way a
bunch of people in flannel shirts and
trucker hats and it couldn't have been a
more obvious example of two Americas
yeah but within the city of Birmingham
Alabama but it's still a city and you
know we see that electorally the divide
Trump does super well among people who
never left the town they were born in
rural people people out in the sticks
and does terrible in the cities and now
much more increasingly in the suburbs
the suburbs are the swing vote the
suburbs last time in 2016 there was a
lot of people in the suburbs who don't
follow politics that closely and they
just said boy things suck in America
let's let the dog drive for a while
let's see what
let's see what let's see what happens
and they didn't you know they won he's a
businessman he must know how to run the
economy and all this stuff we'll try
something new
those people I think first of all a lot
of them have peeled away already those
are the gettable voters those are the
people if the Democrats want to win I
think that they have to target and I
already have but that's why it's a risky
to run someone far left I think if you
run Amy Klobuchar as much as people say
oh she's you know dull and she's this
and she's that and no-one's excited yeah
but again binary at the end of the day
when there's only two choices Trump or
her I think she were very hard for her
to get the nomination I think as far as
like winning the election I think she
would do it fairly easily do you think
that Bernie's to left do these a lot of
the laundry yes do you think that's
really do ask the wrong question
yeah media asks and that there's a
debate tonight the media asks the wrong
question which is what would you do this
is a question that only makes sense if
you're running for King the question
should not be what would you do the
question is what can you get through
what can you propose that Mitch
McConnell will not either block or you
can override with votes because that's a
very different discussion mmm what
Bernie Sanders wants to do we shouldn't
even be talking about because it's not
going to happen
the free education yes back student loan
debt better care for all for all I know
all these well as long as the unless the
Republicans self-deport even if the
Democrat wins the election they're still
going to be half the country that's
Republican and half the Congress is
going to be Republican and this just a
lot of Democrats are not for this stuff
you know when the Democrats took over
the house in 2018 it was moderate
Democrats who won their elections
it wasn't the the far left so so you get
four years of spinning your wheel and
the mud
you get we're hoping to get some
traction you know if he gets in again
it's what can get through Congress what
can you get a consensus
on what what can you make possible Obama
when he did health care said yes if we
were starting from scratch it would make
sense to go for a single-payer system
but we're not starting from scratch
we're starting from a system where most
people already have health insurance
through their employer it's a crazy
story how that happened it was world war
two and they couldn't raise wages
because that was the law so they had to
find a way to give employers something
else so they gave them health insurance
but that's what we have now and a lot of
people like it or say they like it I
don't think a lot of people like arguing
with their insurance company but they're
afraid of something worse and I don't
blame them you know if you're gonna tell
me the government and I'm a Democrat but
if you're gonna tell me the government
is gonna smoothly handle taking over
something that large I am gonna be a
little skeptical we should be they don't
smoothly handle anything there's no
evidence they smoothly handle anything
rather than maybe delivering the news
well I'm delivering the mail look again
as an old-school progressive when you go
down the list of things that the
progressives have accomplished
especially in my lifetime I cheered them
all Social Security that was in my
lifetime but they improved it in my
lifetime Medicare Medicaid these are
great programs
I mean before Social Security the senior
poverty rate was like in the twenty
eight percent or something and then it
went down below ten it was a success but
when you look at what the government
really what their big successes have
amounted to it's passing out money that
very often they don't have that's what
they're really good at running a giant
healthcare system especially when the
politicians who are proposing these
systems will not a talk enough about we
got to cap the gouging you can't pass
out all this money with if you're if
you're going to allow people hospitals
pharmaceutical companies to George chart
anything they want when the price of an
EpiPen can go up from $12 to 1,200
overnight that just can't happen and
also they don't ask the people to lift a
finger to take care of their own health
nobody's health care system is going to
work I'm
you involve people have some sink skin
in the game
you can't like not tell the people look
you can't keep eating as much as you
want and as shitty of food as you want
and expect us to cover the bill
you just can't that is not something
that anybody wants to hear though oh I
know because I did that editorial well
people here's this door people did not
people loved it until James Corden said
something oh that's right he had that
hole
first of all he did that and in doing
that made fat jokes which was which I
did not by the way mine mine was nothing
city sheep on orbit people look morbidly
obese ever first of all he missed a
great opportunity to literally save
lives if he had taken the opposite
approach he took the easy way out
of course you can always get applause
for saying oh let's let's boo the mean
man who's told the truth that's not
brave first of all my point was a that
you can't solve health care unless you
ask the people to participate in that
that was one and also that we've gone to
this place where we're proud of it we're
proud of being unhealthy Weight Watchers
had to take the name weight and Watchers
out of their title
it's WW now it's like wait what it's C
being fat isn't bad what's bad is
someone pointing out that fat is bad
but I mean I read the statistic in that
editorial 40,000 people a month a month
die from obesity that's a crazy number
that is a crazy number we have to
somehow reverse this idea that we have
in this country not just about obesity
but about a lot of things where I'm
perfect the way I am mmm
I am just perfect the way I am and if
you say different you're a very bad
person that's not a good place to be
it's not healthy for anybody you're
you're protecting people's emotions but
shielding them from a possible moment
that might make them realize that they
are eating themselves to death right I
mean look I said it also in the piece
beauties in the eye of the beholder
that's fine whatever you think is
beautiful that's your deal but health is
science yeah
that's science and when we get
apoplectic when there's 50 deaths from
shootings or something a month yeah it's
very bad and we should be serious about
that problem but 50 versus 40,000 every
month and that's just what they're
counting from the big ones cancer
diabetes and heart disease there's
literally nothing about your health that
is improved by being overweight so you
know I said we shouldn't taunt people
but you know compare it to anything else
I also owned up to the fact that I used
to drink too much and I smoked but I
didn't defend it when someone said you
know you went kind of hard last night
with the drinking I didn't say how dare
you drunk shame me well the width I said
you're right I did weird thing about
Corden too is he's not that fat like he
could fix that a couple of months that's
not that hard no he took you know it was
a it was opportunity yes and I felt like
saying yeah he could have he literally
lost an opportunity to save lives
because as someone who does struggle
with weight he could have taken the
opposite approach and said you know he
bill makes a really good point and we
should we should look at how we are
dealing with this I noticed Jillian
Michaels the fitness expert took a lot
of [ __ ] for Liz Oh for Liz oh yeah and
you know if you want to be whatever
weight you want to be that's fine but
it's wrong to shame a fitness expert for
saying this isn't healthy well kids even
said it's not gonna be that amazing when
she gets diabetes yeah of people not
diabetes that's nothing to do it weight
is for sure everything to do with
[ __ ] for sure it also they they they
lie they say things like well it's the
fat gene it's you know there's nothing
it's not that or here's another one and
look this is valid it's valid that in
this country it is a lot
to eat right if you're poor yes
and we should totally address that yes
doubt if it's on any candidates top ten
list but the way the food situation and
subsidies are done in this country is
horrible but given that let's not just
throw up our hands and say we're the
can't do country and because it's harder
let's not even try yes it is harder to
eat right on a budget but I'll tell you
something something you never need to
have with your food soda which is a
large part of it okay and you'll save
money you don't have to have soda you
don't have to have a Snickers bar a
bananas 19 cents so it's not impossible
adèle got [ __ ] recently because she got
yes because she got healthier that's was
also a part of my thing was fit shaming
you know fat shaming fit people go eat
something
eat something I'm fine what so you can
feel better about your weight problem I
should eat and get fat - well when heavy
people have a fan or have someone that
they're a fan of that's also heavy like
James Corden like so he's heavy he's got
people in the audience that love him and
they love him standing up for other
heavy people yeah we're fine we're fine
he's one of us we're fine I think they
felt like that with Adele Adele was this
fantastic singer super talented
extremely popular and overweight like
yeah it's fine it's fine I'm like Adele
everyone's fine it was then she loses
weight like you feel like she's
betraying you because one of the reasons
why I liked you is cuz you're fat yeah
you're not fat anymore it wasn't that
long ago that we were applauding people
when they lost weight yeah I remember
when remember when Oprah came out at
that time was she was this was like in
the 80s I think but she had lost a whole
bunch of where there's a picture you
it's a very famous picture I think she's
she's like in jeans and she's got a like
really thin waist and you know she was
raising your hands and triumphs and
everyone was applauding
I guess that's bad now because again you
have to be perfect the way you are and
if you criticize that then Europe
I think on this it's just that there's
too many voices that you hear because of
social media you hear so many nonsense
voices and they stand out just like
everybody else's voice there's so many
people just screaming into the void
because there's so many social media
accounts of so many people that are
tweeting about things and facebooking
about things and and it gets people
confused is that this is like a rational
perspective and again with echo chambers
they're all just hop on board and
support James Corden or support you know
Adele needs to fatten back up and you'll
get thousands of likes everybody will go
crazy that's the key word yeah that's is
what I didn't understand until about a
year ago that so many people are saying
things on social media not because they
really believe it to get the likes yeah
that's really scary that's weird
we had a billboard once when we were
coming back on the air in January just
like now but four or five years ago and
the tagline was he's not in it for the
likes and it's my favorite piece of
promotion that anyone has ever done for
me that's great he's not in it for the
like yeah advertising that as this is
why you watch the show yeah but
obviously that's not the way a lot of
people feel they are in it for the likes
and they will take a position that they
don't believe in because they know it'll
get likes and I've heard this from
people I actually respect and I'm like
wow you have an addiction that is an
addiction additional likes addiction
yeah there is absolutely that and they
calculate their posts based on the kind
of response they think it's gonna get
it's not like a free expression it's not
like they're they're making a post
saying how I feel about this thing right
writing it down going how are people
going to react to this how am I going to
get people to really think that I'm
awesome how am I gonna get people to
really think I'll progressive really
writing I'm an open-minded person
mmm-hmm the male feminist perspective
right yeah I was just talking to Jimmy
my friend Jimmy Dore about that about
male feminists about that pretty that's
like a wholly false perspective and you
never see it in gay guys there are no
male feminist gay guys because there
trying to [ __ ] the women so it's like
that it's not a position they would take
right it's it's they'll support you
they'll be your friend right this whole
idea I'm a lie I mean I try [ __ ] man
it's so clear it's such an obvious
respect right you know it's just such a
weird sneaky thing yeah but that's it
that's a it's a version of the same
thing people are doing for likes on
social media it's a calculated
expression in order to get you know what
was the kind of response you're hoping
now it's greasy that's grease on the
word I would have thought of but perfect
whenever I read male feminist posts I
get angry I just kick does not i don't
want equality for women I just
you're a greasy man I know you didn't
read your Twitter no me neither
never because she likes exactly well and
and what I read about people very often
who killed themselves oh yeah you know
in the responses that yeah this is a big
thing how about this guy losing his
[ __ ] job for the couldn't you just
yeah could you just stop what he got a
job with the Saints did you like like he
was rich is a better team yeah but I
mean everybody I asked some people who I
know like Barry Weiss who's like
brilliant person and she's like oh my
it's like so depressing like it's like
don't read it oh yes generation cannot
stop reading even when it's going to
kill them I don't understand that well
it's it's very impulsive right you see
your name and you see someone would they
say Oh Barry you're brilliant
oh thank you and then you go a little
further you [ __ ] die and then there's
a bunch of them like in that haunts and
then a bunch of people piling on and
it's you know realizes so first of all
they don't even know you're a real human
a lot of people have never met anyone
famous
they have know that they are looking at
and a lot of them are 15 like well I
always say that if I had a Twitter
account when I was 15
how does it horrible [ __ ] to famous
people right just to get a ride right is
he gonna react to see if I can get him
to react
it's not even things that they
necessarily mean they don't know
you but unless they meet you they don't
even really know you that people take it
to heart so much that they killed
themselves you know a few of these k-pop
stars have killed themselves really look
that up from from a social media yes I
think so I think that's the main reason
and there and these are you know pop
stars yeah
I can't halogen Bobby Sherman right you
know like 68 reading his fan mail and go
yes this one hates me too if Elvis had a
Twitter account hey man
little [ __ ] you give a [ __ ]
Priscilla's 14 yeah come on what the
find a pervert yeah well maybe he could
have used social media back then that's
it right that's the balance like you
don't want Jerry Lee Lewis marrying his
cousin and drowning his wives and you
also don't want Elvis
looking 14 year old maybe be better I
yeah maybe a little bit I own as a
balanced auction you wonder what my life
would have been like as a teenager with
this stuff because maybe it would have
made me kill myself but I was painfully
shy couldn't really talk to a girl if I
had been able to text them maybe think I
would say some [ __ ] I exactly I think I
could have done really well
with that I would had a lot of dick
pictures floating around 100% I would
have sent it to everybody you know
[ __ ] dumb and young you have no you
have no idea that's gonna last forever I
thought that was a humble brag about it
no no it's a regular day just Eddie just
any old day I've sent people other
people's dicks but I would just think
that the whole idea because young boys
love dick pic they draw out of me that
scene in what was the [ __ ] movie
super bad that's one of my favorite
scenes in a movie ever where he's just
drawing dicks and class all yeah it's
[ __ ] hilarious because it's so true
that's so true yeah like we got real
lucky that we are not held up to the
standards that kids are today because
everything they do today that they put
on line they're gonna put a lot of
things online it's permanent for
ever I couldn't imagine something that I
said when I was 14 being permanent and
that points me at back to this thing
about this football player and things
that people write on Twitter it's
something Lucy Kay said to me recently
we're talking about this you said people
look at stuff when it's written down
like it's different but it's just talk
it's talk but it's written like people
say she oh she's a [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
tired of her [ __ ] and then you see her
like oh I'm sorry like but that's talk
right but when you see it written it's
like oh my god did you see what he put
on Twitter to see what he wrote like
you're talking to the whole world now
right and you gotta realize this is
different thing and then people get a
screenshot of it you can never take it
back
yes senator we're gonna keep it forever
we're gonna archive it look he said it
he said she's a [ __ ] [ __ ] and you
can't there's no just talk anymore but
we're wired for just talk people are
wired for gossip and and nonsense talk
especially when you're drinking but if
you're drinking then you get on Twitter
oh you could you could say the dumbest
[ __ ] ever you could take your life and
people have yeah with justine sacco that
famous yes that was one of the first
ones the one who was yeah as soon as you
got off the flight it was upside down
right yeah she gets on a plane it's
almost comical except it's comical you
know she gets on a plane and tweets that
she said something is funny and then by
the time the plane lands her life's over
by the way Family Guy did a hysterical
version of that where Brian the dog goes
into the theater he tweets something
going into a theater and it's semi
racist but it's and then by the time he
comes out of the movie his life is
destroyed by the Twitter mob is
literally a mob outside his house we're
not designed for permanence like that
did you be able to just express yourself
loosely it's like if you're gonna write
something in a book and publish that
book and you're gonna carefully consider
every word and then you put that book
out and you okay we've gone over it we
brought it that's a different thing than
[ __ ] this guy so what do you think
should go on with Louie Louie CK you
mention him I know more about it than
most people because I've talked to Louie
about it but what happened versus what's
being portrayed is what happened there
were there's a lot of stuff
just not true Lackey who's never
blocking anybody's door once and what's
unfair is that he cannot say it he can't
if you if you engage and defend yourself
correct the record then you make it
worse
yeah so you're in this sort of purgatory
where if you hear things that are not
true you also cannot say anything about
it yeah that's a that's a unfair place
to be and also like is everything a
hanging offense my problem with some of
the me to stuff and of course I think
like every right-thinking person it was
a great thing that happened that men
have been put on notice that you're
playing with five fouls and you just
can't get away with a lot of the [ __ ]
you use particular men in positions of
ours plays right I mean I think that's
also extend it to the fracking industry
and McDonald's and every other place in
America where probably it's very
prevalent nobody ever hears about it but
there is just no consistency Charlie
Sheen who I'm not picking on I like him
but he got a Superbowl commercial last
year well he did way worse things and
Louise ek white where's you couldn't
give Louis he can't
so people have like let me see guys in a
Super Bowl commercial that is ridiculous
are lisheen yeah can I Charlie Sheen
because know she and I know but yeah
held a knife to his did he didn't that
time in Aspen wasn't that he was with
the third wife or something and I seem
to remember but he's done man it's being
sued for giving people aids I mean
there's just this litany of things that
are way worse than whacking off in front
of people which is not cool either of
course it's self but literally diddly
little college eyes and own up to it and
I just think the there where is the
consistency yeah look and also where is
the is it a is it all is everything a
life sentence Louis is is a horrible
person forever
or is there some point where we used to
go yes a person pays his debt to society
in some way and then you know I you know
you're allowed back I feel I just feel
bad for him I mean I feel like he did
weird [ __ ] that he shouldn't have done
for sure and I think he knows that I
know he knows that but what is the
proper punishment and is and who decides
it well he's definitely working again so
all the people that are complaining and
bitching about her sees no one here
knows his doing he's touring again right
yeah when you selling his tickets to his
fans yeah sure but he certainly can't do
everything he wants to do right and he
can't he can still tour but even if he
wants to do a special boy who's gonna
take him up on that right you know who's
gonna jump jump the law and maybe maybe
the proper punishment is another five
years before you can have a special but
that's a long time well I'm just saying
I'm just pulling it out of my ass I'm
just saying what we need some sort of
it's been more than two years some sort
of me to court yeah that a fair and just
adjusted by Judge Rose McGowan presiding
yeah yeah how would you how do you
decide when you know a person has been
punished enough and and what is the
governor yeah but he's got some
hilarious bits about it because so the
problem was I like jerking off and I
don't like being alone right and I
wanted to the rest of the material he
does about it but you know he asked he
asked can I jerk off in front of you
when they said yes he did it it's not a
good thing
nothing's good about any you know but
and he knows it and I'm not defending
him but right people are portraying it
is far worse than like he went up at
skank fest in New York and people went
crazy and cheered and I reposted the
video of it and someone posted on
Twitter one of the rare times I look
[ __ ] you Joe Rogan he assaulted women
yeah no like no he didn't no but he
didn't you're gonna can't change where
salt means right he asked if he could
jerk off in front of people and then he
did
there's some question as to whether or
not a jerked off on the phone with
somebody I don't think that's assault
either it's kind of creepy not even
kinda it's time she would say it's
creepy but we're not talking about
someone assaulted people like you you
can't just change the definition of the
word because it makes you feel better
about hating someone now I also read but
I don't know if it's true if his
management I think threatened women who
were gonna talk about this or prevented
someone's career from moving because of
this if that happened that to me is
almost worse yes that's a guerrilla beds
yes
agree I don't know if that's true and
he's not allowed to talk to straighten
that out well it's not that he's not
allowed to talk well it would be it was
been considered talking about it a few
times and I think he just he decides at
the end of the day it's just better just
keep pushing ahead and right and his new
hour apparently I'm not advertising for
it but from everybody that I heard it's
[ __ ] amazing cuz all the pain all the
craziness he apparently has a book about
new material rock and knew I talked
about something to talk about
I do cuz it's like a work night for me
boy up tell people when is it when's the
new season air Friday this Friday
yeah the 17th to January same bat-time
same bat-channel HBO at 10:00 Eastern
and I guess you can figure out the other
time zones from that and we're gonna go
back at it again plenty to talk about
plenty to talk about always see
congratulations by the way on making
this such a big stop and such an iconic
place you did good thank you thank you I
don't know what the [ __ ] happened
stumbled into it will you do my show
sure okay I asked you before and you
were very squirrely about the people
they're all talking over each other over
stand by you know I heard you say that
one yeah when you're some guy doing a
terrible impression of me and and it's a
very tile kolinsky it is a great
impression of you
I didn't know who he was have you ever
seen the face off faith of Face Swap
version that he does of you on Instagram
no oh I don't know find that before we
leave
what's that cutlet kolinsky sorry sorry
Kyle no we don't have to look at this
I'm Emily it's amazing to you it was
amazing it wasn't yeah I don't man I
people done me and I can laugh at it
something it was your face he's got your
face I was doing an impression of you
you've never seen it it's not I saw what
anyway the point yeah that doesn't
matter the point was what was the point
a point was there's not too many people
talking over each other on your show
correct
I feels like it is to me it's very
difficult to have a conversation when
there's so many different people talking
it's such a fundamental criticism of my
show it's not his show is just that
format that's the size but that's of
that which I think you're thinking
you're politically incorrect was that
way I'm thinking of your show right now
well I'm there every week okay and I try
I monitor it pretty closely of course
when you have a panel which we do there
can be those moments but we don't book
that kind of person and that kind of
show
it's not the old let's get them fighting
thing we don't want that and honestly
the number of times when people have
been shouting over each other and you
can't hear them is very little it's not
even that they're shouting over each
others if you have a point you want to
talk about something you got to let it
was a little hesitation but you would be
the mid show guest to my left and it
would be a one-on-one you know I do a
one-on-one twice on the show have you
seen the show okay in the middle of the
show yeah I bring out more of a
celebrity usually to my left I would be
tossed in one wears one harris start
going at it with ben affleck because of
that Sam was your one-on-one that's
right okay well that's you know you
picked the one example where somebody
that's what you were talking about I
think you've seen one show Jordan
Peterson glad we only
don't demand that anyone be effete I
just like honesty one of my favorite how
we're getting woozy honest Hitchens went
after most deaf well he's been dead for
like ten years so what we're
establishing your knowledge of this show
is very limited so I watched a bunch
episode I hope you to watch Yeti I don't
need you to have I have lots of fans I'm
not don't need one more what I'm saying
is I'd like you to do it because I think
you'd be good
and I like listening to you and you'd be
to my left one on one there would be
nobody shouting over you because they
wouldn't be involved okay so you
wouldn't have that problem so will you
do it yes great all right and then we'll
work on it shin will work on Hawaii all
right all right
Bill Marley's thank you thank you
pleasure to be here man yeah
[Music]